[Music]
i'm joanne chang and over the next 30
days i'm going to teach you how to go
from following recipes to creating your
own
you're going to learn the foundations of
cakes cookies pies and brioche i'm going
to help you become a more confident and
creative baker
flower is a bakery and cafe that i
started over 20 years ago this class is
a little bit like coming into flower and
learning the things that i teach my
bakers throughout our journey together i
will provide you with help assignments
and guidance every step of the way
i need some room behind every great
baker there is a strong community which
is why you'll be taking this class with
an active group of pastry makers just
like you who will give you supportive
feedback we're going to learn as a group
bake as a group and grow as a group
when we're finished here you're going to
have all the tools you need to bake like
a pro
this is more than just recipes and
beautiful pastries on a plate
after 30 days you'll have learned
techniques that will elevate anything
and everything you bake in the future
beautiful oh my gosh i'm joanne chang
and this is masterclass
[Music]
you